so any of you guys ever heard of a
tournament organizer called global
electronic sports championship neither
had I well anyways they hosted two dota
miners last season they haven't tweeted
in like nineteen months and uh oh yeah
they're reportedly being sued by valve
for at least seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars so what the [ __ ] did
they do
so before I even get into the lawsuit
this whole thing actually started well
over a year ago in October of 2018
that's when an open letter to valve and
the eSports community at large was
posted online this open letter claims to
represent quote a group including teams
players talent and agencies that
attended GE SC events in 2018 and
alleges the GES see that's that global
electronic sports championship owes 750
thousand dollars in unpaid fees these
fees include prize money going to
players and teams and payment to
production workers and talent these
allegations all stem from two dota
events that took place last year in
March and May GE SC Indonesia and GE SC
Thailand as minors these events featured
three hundred thousand dollars in prize
pools one hundred fifty thousand from GE
SC themselves and a hundred and fifty
thousand kicked in from daddy valve and
competitively these were not
insignificant events teams like fnatic
evil geniuses team secret not as Finn's
a are all competed and they weren't just
competing for that prize money they were
battling for DPC points the qualifying
points needed to attend the
International the biggest dota thing in
existence something that has tens of
millions of dollars in prize money now
as far as the players at these events go
the open letter claims that GE SC had an
agreement with the valve to pay out
prize money within 90 days of the
tournaments an agreement that they
obviously broke if now much more than a
year later they haven't been properly
paid yet who exactly wrote this letter
is it made a hundred percent explicit
but the director of team secret did
tweet it out originally and dota heavy
hitters like blitz and redeye and others
have also chimed in on the convo
although so side notes speaking of
redeye
apparently the CEO of GE SC a guy named
Oscar Fang was shopping around some
thing called Project hero and attached
red eyes named to it yeah so some
alleged slides from a fundraising
presentation for project hero leaked
last year on a website called games is
hard GG
if these slides are authentic they show
that Fang was asking for four million
dollars in funding and listing gese
Thailand and gese Indonesia as proof of
success and had red eyes name attached
to it as his eSports consultant red eye
and his consultancy agency Code Red
eSports denied everybody hearing about
whatever project hero is let alone
working on we haven't even gotten to the
lawsuit yet and already we have these
two disastrous tournaments that
allegedly did not pay people out and red
eye being falsely attached to some
project that no one knows what it is
things are getting pretty sketchy
anyways back to the open letter the
people who drafted it the people who
haven't been paid yet said that they
gave this Fang guy multiple attempts to
try and reimburse them we're very
patient with them got promises promises
promises from him and then he allegedly
ghosted them which is why they ended up
drafting a public letter oh yeah and GE
SC were supposed to host for DotA miners
last season not two but two of them in
Malaysia and Singapore respectively were
cancelled for basically no reason in
hindsight that was maybe not the worst
thing that ever happened to the DPC
flash forward to 2019 and valve is
reportedly suing GE SC in the High Court
of the Republic of Singapore for failure
to pay money owed this bombshell came by
way of a dot esports report written by
George Geddes in that report the
existence of this lawsuit is confirmed
by Valve's VP of Marketing who is Doug
Lombardi Lombardi told dot eSports that
at this point valve is no longer
considering working with GE SC saying
quote our agreements with tournament
operators required timely payment to
participants we feel this is vital to
the success of these events a long-term
and quote now as far as ge SC itself and
their CEO go well it seems like they
pretty much disappeared from the world
of eSports for over a year now their
website is pretty much dead since they
hosted those dota miners in 2018 and
their Facebook Instagram and Twitter
pages haven't posted anything in over a
year
what I really want to do in this case is
access the actual lawsuit read through
the documents and tell you guys in
detail what they actually say turns out
though accessing court documents in
Singapore is
a lot more difficult than it is in the
US apparently to even request access to
these documents I have to apparently
attend at the legal registry located at
level 2 of the Supreme Court with a hard
copy of the completed request form and
proper identification to seek the
approval of the registrar end quote yeah
pretty sure that's not gonna happen
that's not going to happen I did of
course reach out to GE SC for comment
but as of this recording I have got zero
response yet now this news comes hot on
the heels of another scandal involving
an eSports tio that has allegedly failed
to pay out their talent or at least
failed to pay them in a timely manner
earlier this month Richard Lewis
revealed that starladder the organizers
of the most recent csgo major were late
in paying out their talent who worked
that event this whatever you want to
call it epidemic phenomenon of TOS
failing to pay people in a timely manner
or breaking agreements or ignoring
invoices when it comes to talent is
something that I've been personally
looking into on the side as well in fact
I've talked to several csgo on-air
talents personally who have experienced
chronic issues with late payments so far
they haven't been willing to talk to me
on the record about it for fear
legitimate fear that they could be at
best treated differently by those TOS
and at worst blacklisted by them for
speaking out now since the starladder
report since the report about gese i
really feel like i might need to go
harder on this trail and try and get
people to come out on the record if you
guys want me to do a report like that
and investigate this for the score I
mean go ahead and comment about it tweet
at me and you know what we'll get on it
I don't know what my favorite Christmas
movie is top movies you gotta watch her
and Christmas our Christmas family
vacation number one with a bullet a home
alone one and/or two just just ask to
your Christmas [ __ ] right there after
after that it goes downhill it's one of
it's a wonderful life I mean how few
[ __ ] kids don't know what that is
it is a long ass black and white movie I
usually like that [ __ ] I find it long
and boring you know
I buy that and on that here's a nice
little pic for you guys how about the
holiday classic jingle all the way
starring Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Sinbad trying to get the turbo man doll
for my child
ah total man I was big movie star back
then Sinbad where'd he go